les entreprises made in bourgogne
franche comté qui rayonne à
l'international et qu'on aime vous
présenter et vous allez peut-être
découvrir une entreprise que vous ne
connaissiez pas et pourtant vous avez
peut-être dormi dans un dans un celi pas
vraiment parce que vous ne fabrique pas
des lignes vous fabriquer tous les
articles de literie
c'est avant tout une aventure familiale
et noir thomas racontez moi ça alors oui
c'est une entreprise familiale depuis
cinq générations puisque je suis la
cinquième je viens de reprendre
l'entreprise ne puis cette année tout
juste et puis nous fabriquons 100 % de
nos produits à tonnerre à côté de
chablis dans l'yonne où nous avons 45
personnes qui fabriquent au quotidien
oreiller couette surmatelas édredon
traversin et tous ses produits avec une
certaine fierté je le redis label du
patrimoine vivant pour une entreprise ça
veut dire quelque chose
oui parce que ans il n'y a que mille
quatre cent mille cinq cents entreprises
labellisées aujourd'hui en france
quand on connaît la panoplie des
entreprises françaises avec tous ses
savoir faire c'est c'est plutôt une
reconnaissance oui alors de fil en
aiguille s'enfuir de vilain jeu de mots
à vous arrêter à fabriquer les oreilles
les traversées au départ c'était passé à
l'entreprise alors non on a on a en a
pas toujours fait ça au gré des des
retournements économiques on a on a su
évoluer
initialement on a acheté l'entreprise de
récupération on a récupéré des fleurs
des dû faire des choses comme ça et on
s'est spécialisé dans les peaux de
lapins jusqu'à l'épuisement des cette
récupération parce que le couvre-chef
à péricliter avec l'essor de la voiture
là les manteaux aussi en peau de lapin
complètement disparu avec l'essor de la
mode américaine qui est arrivé après
guerre et donc on a récupéré
principalement des plumes et duvets qui
venait à peu près des mêmes canaux de
récupération et on s'est mis à après
coup à fabriquer des premiers oreiller
en 54 exactement dans le moulin où sont
au bureau aujourd'hui à à tonnerre voilà
depuis les premiers oreiller il ya eu
d'autres choses qu'on va découvrir mais
je fais durer un petit peu le suspense
parce que je me dis j'ai un spécialiste
de laurier vous êtes certainement comme
moi vous avez envie de choisir à beaune
oreiller il suffit pas de mettre le prix
dans un bon oreiller même si on comprend
que la qualité ça se paye évidemment va
pas être naïf mais malgré tout ce qui
est des astuces pour repérer le bon
oreiller
alors en fait on a on a développé deux
de marque une qui est plus accessible en
termes de prix et mémé qui ne ne ne
transige pas sur le choix le choix du
bon produit
en fait on dort bien quand on a un
produit adapté on a fait tout un tas
d'études notamment avec le centre
national du sommeil et de la vigilance
de l'hôtel dieu à paris qui nous a
permis de vérifier et confirmer tout un
tas d'éléments notamment le
questionnaire que l'on a mis au point et
qui permet d'orienter vers un produit
adapté
on a des gains importants et
significatifs de sommeil puisqu'on parle
de quand même de 25 minutes et j'étais
en train de me dire il en train de faire
une réponse de politique le garçon la
edward la première question c'était
comment choisir bonneriez juste avant
que vous réfléchissiez à la vraie
réponse
j'ai envie de me tourner vers aurélie
haïti fait préférer un ouvrier du only
un oreiller mou dur dur
alors il ya deux durs de ce côté là
perso moi c'est mi-dure mi mouche qu'est
ce qu'il faut comme auriez alors il faut
un oreiller qui soit adaptée à sa
morphologie et à sa façon de dormir ça
veut dire ça veut dire qu'un oreiller 1
comment on ira un dormeur qui dort sur
le ventre va forcément avoir ne pas
avoir les mêmes besoins qu'un dormeur
sur le côté et puis une personne qui
fait un mètre 95 est qui et qui
ressemble à teddy riner il n'a pas le
même besoin
edouard la clôture alors l'on clair j'ai
un oreiller devant moi celui ci l'ait
fait pour quoi pour qui celui ci c'est
un oreiller qui va être fait pour une
personne comme vous qui dort sur le côté
principalement d'accord puisque c'est un
confort ou intermédiaire est qui et qui
permet d'avoir un maintien et surtout vu
la taille de le rendre quand même
relativement modules à vous pouvez vous
pouvez l'ajuster en fonction et
l'adapter à votre morphologie
ok il ya des oreillers en longueur moi
j'en vois partout maintenant des choses
à l'oreille et rectangulaire est alors
en fait c'est celle intermédiaire entre
le traversin et l'oreiller c'est une
forme qui est arrivé des etats-unis
principalement et qui permet fortement
de dormir sur le côté d'accord il ya des
garnissages qui sont forcément
différents 1 dans ses oreillers là je
vois que vous m'avez emmené deux espèces
de vers à l'intérieur il ya deux
produits différents
alors que c'est pour représenter les
deux grandes familles de nos de nos
produits
enfin dans les garnissages vous avez les
garnissages synthétique qui sont du
festayre voilà tout à fait seydoux et
que l'on garde donc là on est sur le
haut de gamme du synthétique bien
évidemment toutes les toutes les
typologies de fibres et puis on a
également le naturel ici avec avec du
duvet et et on n'a jamais rien fait de
mieux que ce que fait la nature
et voilà les duvets les jolies duvet de
canard que l'on voit là et qui viennent
garnir en grand nombre de nos articles
obligé de terminer j'éternue déjà
naturellement aujourd'hui jeunes plumes
comme ça y'a pas d'allergie
nécessairement avec avec le naturel
à part si c'est avéré il ya eu beaucoup
de d'éléments
allergènes liés aux acariens et est en
fait eu pour un bon entretien et éviter
les acariens dans la chambre il faut
aérer tous les matins on air
alors on choisit le bon oreiller même si
c'est un peu compliqué de savoir
exactement lequel trappe attention à la
pléiade en moi malgré tout il yad'autres
d'autres choses très à la mode le
surmatelas on en a peut-être pas là ici
des mets sur matelas on en voit beaucoup
de plus en plus tout à fait donc on a on
a mis au point pour une grande chaîne
hôtelière dans les années 2001 une
combinaison d'articles comprenant un
surmatelas c'est un des plus grands
groupes hôteliers français mais pour
nous en bourgogne france comté qui
voulons par exemple acheter un
surmatelas le meilleur conseil c'est
quoi choisir une certaine épaisseur
alors oui vous avez déjà bas encore une
fois là le choix entre le synthétique ou
naturel et puis après c'est ce que vous
voulez y est principalement l'effet
waouh que l'on retrouve dans le sur
matelas c'est dans le naturel avec une
épaisseur assez assez importante repasse
le cas chez edwards il ya eu un effet
whaou sur ce plateau tout à l'heure
quand vous avez posé cette couette la
cette couette qui est ici tout le monde
a fait ou à vous les jeunes vous êtes
plutôt couette ou plutôt plutôt
couvertures couettes y ait quoi est on a
deux couettes 3 kw est avec moi les
traits quoi toi c'est vrai que
maintenant c'est la couette parce que
voilà on est tous un peu à peu près
c'est on va dire il matin juste pour
faire le lit en 3d c'est fait la bonne
cause comment on la choisit alors c'est
pareil on a tout un questionnaire sur la
question la bonne cause comment les
choisir quand on l'a choisi en fonction
en fonction de la température de sa
chambre de son environnement de sommeil
des attentes que l'on a si on est plutôt
frileux ou plutôt plus tôt ayant chaud
toute la nuit
on peut vraiment adapté son son choix de
produits on a donc des produits qui sont
plus à destination de période de l'année
comme l'était donc des couettes légère
qui sont faciles à utiliser et qui sont
très peu chaude et puis après vous avez
un apport de chaleur plus importants sur
des couettes plutôt orienté hiver et
avec des grammages un peu plus sérieux
en termes de duvet et 1 apporte chaleur
conséquent si on revient sur
l'entreprise et ils doivent thomas
l'avenir vous vous voyez comment
toujours dans le lit dans les
accessoires de lits où vous allez vous
diversifier alors la diversification
c'est quelque chose que l'on n'envisage
pas encore pour la simple et bonne
raison c'est que j'ai j'ai eu beaucoup
de contacts avec mon grand-père dans la
transmission des savoirs et est un des
uns des savoirs a été pour le thé voilà
d'un des dictons familiale c'est c'est
de dire que bien faire ce qu'on sait
faire c'est déjà pas mal c'est déjà pas
mal
donc aujourd'hui on se concentre encore
sur l'évolution de nos produits et à
l'innovation dans nos produits la
compagnie thomas dumas dumas pardon on a
tous rectifier un fleuron de la région
une affaire de famille oui ça je les ai
compris depuis au moins cinq générations
et mon avis c'est parti pour durer
encore et qu'à voir votre sourire et ça
c'est ça c'est très bien on était
content de vous montrer sa 6ème
d'ailleurs excusez-moi de vous couper
mais je passe un appel j'en profite
oui à la recherche d'une administratrice
des ventes de l'emploi en plus à
pourvoir grâce à france 3 met sa main gm
basé à tonnerre sagem dites moi il doit
ré ce que vous portez une montre oui bon
j'ai une autre fierté locale à vous
montrer avec l'horlogerie l'horlogerie
qui sa fille dans
dans un complexe un petit peu
particulier avec deux nouvelles marques
made in france je vous propose d'aller à
la rencontre de leurs créateurs et puis
nous revenons ensemble on aura
certainement quand l'occasion de parler
un petit peu de quelques articles de
literie d'abord on se met à l'heure il
l'a appelé routine mais en réalité ça
montre n'a rien d'un défi ordinaire
florian jeune ingénieur de 28 ans avait
décidé de faire une vraie montre
françaises labellisées origine france
garantie quand je présente mon projet il
ya deux ans les gens me disent ouais le
made in france florian ça coûte très
cher aujourd'hui il suffit d'assembler
en france pour que les messieurs les
montres se vendent pas besoin d'avoir
une démarche jusqu'au boutiste et puis
en fait aujourd'hui je démontre un petit
peu le contraire ça montre sera vendu
295 euros est bel et bien fabriquer de
86 % de composants français 13 des 14
fournisseurs de florian sont en france
dont neuf en franche-comté moment à
quartz est aussi français au sens oui
les mêmes assemblées en france à partir
de nombreux composants français tout à
fait c'est un bouillonnement et c'est
vrai qu'on est ravi de mettre en
relation nous des jeunes créateurs comme
ça avec des fabricants des fournisseurs
tout ça pour les aider à accélérer un
petit peu les choses
eux aussi ont décidé de créer une
nouvelle marque du très haut de gamme
entièrement dessinés et fabriqués ici à
palente à deux pas de l'ancien site lipp
à l'origine du projet ces deux hommes
l'un designer chez peugeot l'autre
ingénieur horloger côté suisse le
résultat c'est une montre qui évoque
l'automobile et relève de vrais défis
techniques à l'image des aiguilles qu'il
a fallu plier pour arriver à nos fins on
ne devait avoir une aiguille qui était
avec un seul clic
aucun sous-traitant suisse ne pouvait
nous faire ou ou français ne pouvait
nous faire ses aiguilles donc on a
décidé de les faire en interne c'est à
dire que même en a rajouté une
complexité on a fait deux plis et c'est
l'horloger maxime qui clients internes
un horloger de haut vol qui a fait le
choix de quitter la grande maison suisse
qui l'employait pour mettre en oeuvre le
projet des deux associés seront tous
unis les deux aventures en fait de
participer à quelque chose et puis
refaire un peu renaître d'horlogerie en
france seuls quelque chose qui me tenait
vraiment à coeur
cinq montres par mois sortiront de
l'atelier à 55000 euros pièce hors taxes
le côté français
se retrouvent dans cette audace à la
fois esthétique et à la fois stylistique
et c'est pour ça qu'à un moment donné on
a probablement le fait le choix d'être
de ce côté là de la frontière et de
revendiquer comme une marque de luxe
éminemment design éminemment stylistique
mais avec une cohérence technique
une audace qui a déjà séduit à londres
singapour ou paris des clients très
riche qui attendaient qu'on les
surprenne montre de créateur ou pas il
est précisément 10h09 et j'ai encore
envie de vous poser quelques questions
pour mieux dormir je le disais tout à
l'heure on passe un tiers de sa vie au
lit donc tant qu'à faire on va en
profiter puisque on a un spécialiste
edward dumas entreprise familiale de la
région depuis cinq générations dans
l'yonne
dites moi il ya des couacs et des
oreillers est ce qu'il ya une fréquence
pour changer son oreiller ce qui est un
signe avant coureur
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose par
exemple alors c'est pas évident de
déterminer les signes avant-coureurs de
la fatigue d'un oreiller sans faire de
jeu de mots de l'eau mais mais c'est
vrai que un tassement est observée est
observable à presse et c'est aussi un
peu de connaissance de soi même il faut
pas attendre d'avoir mal que tu es matin
d'avoir aussi des migraines le matin
et un peu moins de fraîcheur au réveil
il faut renouveler son oreiller j'ai
aujourd'hui on est en train de le
déterminer
on va dire scientifiquement avec des
essais libres 2 en laboratoire mais
c'est au tour de trois ans et pour une
courette par exemple et pour une couette
sur des couettes comme celles que vous
avez sous la main
on est sur des couettes très haut de
gamme et là vous avez vous avez une
couette qui peut durer une quinzaine
d'années si c'est très bien entre edward
on n'a pas parlé primé une fourchette ça
vaut combien une dent creuse comme ça
alors une couette comme ça vous pouvez
monter sur des lits de grande taille
puisque forcé france a évolué avec la
taille aussi vous fait du sur mesure
aussi exactement et de la
personnalisation puisqu'en on
personnalise avec grâce à des broderies
des oreillers lit couettes
mais on peut monter jusqu'à jusqu'à de
3000 euros sans problème même à huy et
les les plus et privé plus isolé plus au
pardon c'est au tour de 10000 euros
d'accord mais sur des cuvées d'exception
la voilà on est sur l'excellence à il
est bon de le préciser
parce qu'il ya beaucoup plus bas aussi
puisque vous travaillez pour des
enseignes qu'on connaît tous des
magasins à petit prix je vais pas tous
les citer parce que ça va faire un peu
de pub mais voilà des choses beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus abordable très
abordable pour tout le monde tout à fait
pas de soucis allez juste avant de
terminer en deux secondes dit pascal
leblanc est toujours la couleur à la
mode alors le blanc oui parce que parce
que c'est ça permet d'avoir une cette
couleur immaculée dans un lycée quand
même assez agréable d'avoir sept
couleurs fraîches mais bien évidemment
on fait des oreillers aussi de couleurs
et un pour tout un tas de distributeurs
mais mais les maisons que l'on a sont
principalement orientées sur le blanc